amine benyamina merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer de façon générale quelles
conséquences psychologiques peut avoir
un confinement de longue durée sur
l'ensemble de la population
ben confinement de longue durée a une
conséquence particulière entre
population générale c'est d'abord de
l'anxiété symptômes ou bien ça
un trait que tout le monde doit partager
et ensuite la manière avec laquelle
cette entité va aimer dépend d'abord des
personnes dépendaient des lieux et la
manière avec laquelle on est confiné et
dépend aussi de la perception qu'on a du
confinement et puis la perspective qu'on
a du confinement mais tout le monde est
plus ou moins anxieux et tout le monde
gère différemment sans l'accepter alors
oui néanmoins qu'ils sont les personnes
les plus vulnérables six allemands face
à ce problème dont on parle peu
évidemment les personnes les plus
vulnérables
ce sont les personnes qui qui sont
malades sur le plan psychiatrique ou
psychologiques notamment les façons que
l'on voit régulièrement ses les
personnes qui viendront également nous
voir pour des pathologies réelle n'était
des troubles dépressifs des troubles
bipolaires de l'anxiété qui les unit
dans la vie de tous les jours des
malades schizophrènes qui en a
l'habitude d'aller voir les équipes les
médecins les infirmiers qui prend le
retraitement océan ritualisé finalement
ce soin et qui se retrouve en quelque
sorte livrés à eux mêmes dans un espace
qui n'est jamais un espace rassurant
pour alain laristan très important pour
ces patients parce que ce sont des
patients qui parfois se retrouve à avoir
des idées noires des idées morbides
avec au bout le risque et qui est le
plus le plus souvent pour un médecin
psychiatre c'est évidemment le suicide
on verra c'est la prévalence du sida
augmenté après le confinement et dans
quelques compilations mais il faut voir
ça en tête
mais à part ça on à faire souvent des
populations qui sont son plan social
déshérités qui sont d'un niveau soccer
économique bas ils sont confinés dans
des lieux dans un endroit très difficile
et quand ils n'ont pas des idées noires
qu'il gère probablement comme ils
peuvent et bêtes peuvent les gérer par
des mauvaises pratiques notamment par
par la prise de toxiques par la pluie de
drogue par d'après d'alcool et donc on
voit qu'on a à faire à la double peine
d'abord ils subissent la pandémie
confinement compte tout le monde
il subit encore pathologie et je pense
que cette deuxième map dont on parle
beaucoup et souvent contraints locaux
vides
c'est peut-être ces pathologies
chroniques qui est qu'on n'a pas
sous-estimer oublié mais qui qui n'a qui
n'osent pas finalement faire parler
d'elle et qui risquent d'être à l'eau un
portant a quant à lui déjà prêt alors
est ce que les patients qui souffrent
déjà de pathologies comme des addictions
des troubles psychiatriques est ce qu
ils peuvent développer d'autres troubles
justement avec ce confinement
ils peuvent mangerez à leur table quand
ils sont malades ils peuvent majorer
leurs troupes
ils peuvent probablement faire ce qu'on
appelle des comorbidités par exemple les
patients indiquent qu'ils ont été non
pas de comorbidité psychiatre peuvent se
retrouver à générer des problèmes
dépressifs ou anxieux et les patients
psychiatriques
quand ils ont la possibilité et ils
peuvent s'adonner à des prises de drogue
voilà donc mais à côté de ça il ya
d'autres éléments qui peuvent
équipements qui peuvent apparaître
c'est probablement des violences
intrafamiliales lesotho ou des et or
agressivité terre ans fait mal à soi et
aux autres et ce sont des choses qu'il
faut avoir en tête ne sont pas plus
exposés mais ils sont plus fragiles pour
gérer ce type de stress qu'ils répondent
plus
alors face à ces situations comment vous
les psychiatres vous vous adaptez
aujourd'hui dans cette situation qu de
colis de 19
on a deux possibilités comme à
d'ailleurs dû en place d'abord en effet
de maintenir le lien avec nos passions
par de la téléconsultation par des
d'appel par tout ce qu'on a pu mettre en
place certains continuent à venir
notamment les passions de secteurs mais
au compte gouttes et dans un parcours
sécurisé et puis on s'est mis à
disposition de la population générale
avec les déplacements d'un d'écouté
d'appel à la fois pour les gens mais
aussi pour d'autres soignants les
soignants sont sont très impactées
d'abord parlons peu vite et ensuite par
le stress et par l'hyper importance de
la mobilisation sans répit sans répit
qui subissaient donc les psychiatres
sont là à la fois pour leur propre
passion pour la population générale et
pour les soignants les collègues dont
m'ont servi par exemple en bien en place
à travers les équipes des psychiatres de
psychologues étaient ceux d'essence de
pleine conscience de mayonnaise de
relaxation
et de celui des coûte à la fois pour les
soignants mais aussi pour les familles
vous savez comme moi que mais hélas dans
certaines dans certains cas l'arrêt
aliments sur martin a sauvé désir on a
des décès et il est et tout ce qui est
effectué de séparation par la mort je ne
sais pas et les familles sont dans un
cas possible pour qu'on est là pour les
écouter d aider aussi merci beaucoup
amine benyamina d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
psychiatre et addictologue